hi everyone this is Professor M does
science and in this video I want to tell
you about the translation operator as
the name says the translation operator
is the one that allows us to move
quantum states from one point to another
so why do we care about translation
operator the main reason is because it
allows us to understand many properties
avoid functions of these perhaps the
most famous is the fact that the wave
function in real space is related to the
wave function in momentum space by a
Fourier transform so what I want to do
in this video is pretty straightforward
I want to introduce the translation
operator and we want to look at the
number of its properties that are useful
when working with wave functions so
let's get going to style the translation
operator we need to start by considering
the position X and momentum P operators
whose most important property is their
commutator which is equal to I h-bar so
let's look at the translation operator
and we start by defining it as t alpha
equal to e to the minus I alpha P over H
bar where alpha is a real parameter for
the time being we're going to take this
as the definition of the translation
operator and only later on in the video
we're going to prove that in fact it is
an operator that translates by an amount
alpha by looking at its definition of
the translation operator you may wonder
what it means to have a function of an
operator like the exponential function
here the short answer is that the
function of an operator is defined by
its Taylor expansion and if you haven't
seen the video yet where I talk about
functions of operators to check the link
in the description whenever we introduce
a new operator we need to understand
some of its properties the most
important one is typically the adjoint
of the operator which tells us about
what the operator looks like in the dual
space
so let's write T dagger alpha and this
will be equal to e to the I alpha P
dagger over H bar then we remember that
the momentum operator is hermitian so P
dagger is equal to P which gives us e to
the I alpha P over H bar if we rearrange
the exponent we then obtain e to the
minus I minus alpha P over H bar and we
then look at the definition of the
translation operator up here we see that
it is nothing more than t minus alpha
what this means is that the adjoint of
the operator T alpha is equal to t minus
alpha
so an immediate consequence of these is
that the translation operator is not
hermitian to investigate for the
properties of the translation operator
let's look at the action of T dagger
alpha on T alpha and explicitly writing
this down we obtain e to the I alpha P
over H bar e to the minus I alpha P over
H bar and combining these two exponents
gives us the identity remember that in
general we cannot combine exponents of
operators like if they were numbers but
in this case we can because the two
exponents commute because the P operator
commutes with itself if we look at the
complementary relation we find that T
alpha T dagger alpha is equal to e to
the minus I alpha P over H bar e to the
I alpha P over H bar which again gives
us the identity putting these two
results together tells us that the
adjoint of an operator T alpha is equal
to the inverse of the operator and
you'll remember that an operator whose
adjoint is equal to its inverse is
called a unitary operator if you need
for the details about unitary operators
to check the video linked in the
description where I talked about them so
far we have introduced the operator T
alpha which we have called the
translation operator although we haven't
yet proved that it is indeed a
translation operator but nonetheless we
have looked at a number of its
properties and we have figured out that
the adjoint of the operator is equal to
its inverse so it is a unitary operator
and additionally these two terms are
also equal to t minus alpha before we
can prove that the operator T alpha is
indeed a translation operator we need to
look at an additional property of this
operator which is its commutator with
the position operator so let's write
down the commutator of X with T alpha
which explicitly is equal to the
commutator of X with a to the minus I
alpha P over H bar so what is the
commutator of an operator with a
function of another operator you can
find full details in a video link in the
description but at the summary we have
that four operators a and B such that
they each commute with their commutator
that is the commutator of a with the
commutator of a and B is equal to 0 and
the commutator of B with the commutator
of a and B is also equal to 0 then for
such operators we can write that the
commutator of a
with a general function f of B is equal
to the commutator of a and B multiplied
by the derivative of the function of B
if we now look back at the commutator
interested in we see that the relevant
operators are X and P and therefore we
need to calculate the commutator of X
with the commutator of X and P which is
equal to 0 and likewise the commutator
of P with the commutator of X and P is
also equal to 0 of course both results
following from the canonical commutation
relation which serves as the de
commutator of X and P is equal to IH bar
we can now finally put all these results
together to evaluate the commutator we
started with and we find that the
commutator of X with the Alpha is equal
to the commutator of X with P times the
derivative of the Alpha which is equal
to minus I alpha over H bar e to the
minus I alpha P over H bar
we know that the commutator of X and P
is IH bar we also can recognize this
term as the Alpha and we can therefore
write the final expression as equal to
alpha T alpha with this commutator we
now have all the ingredients that we
need to prove that the T alpha operator
is indeed a translation operator let us
start by looking at the eigenvalue
equation for the position operator x hat
acting on the cat x is equal to the
eigenvalue x acting on the cat X and
then we consider the action of the
position operator on a new cat which is
formed by the action of T alpha on the
cat X using the commutator we have just
proved we can write XT alpha as equal to
alpha T alpha plus T alpha X and we can
plug this expression in the equation
above to obtain alpha T alpha plus T
alpha X acting on X is equal to alpha T
alpha X plus T alpha X hat X this last
term is simply the eigenvalue x acting
on the cat X and therefore combining
both terms we obtain alpha plus X T
alpha acting on the cat X so what do
these results mean well they mean that
if the cat X is an eigenvector of the
operator x with eigenvalue x then the
cat t alpha x is also an eigenvector of
the operator x with eigenvalue x-bar
alpha what this means is that we can
write that the action of the operator T
alpha on a cat X gives us another cat X
plus alpha so indeed we confirm that the
T alpha operator is a translation
operator that translates a cat by an
amount alpha it does also make sense now
to remember that the inverse of the
operator T alpha is equal to t minus
alpha because if this operator
essentially translates cats then a
translation by alpha has an inverse at a
translation by minus alpha before we
finish I want to derive two additional
properties of the translation operator
that are very useful when studying many
quantum mechanical problems the first
one is to look at what the translation
operator looks like in dual space so we
write the action of T minus alpha on X
as equal to X minus alpha and the
corresponding expression in dual space
is that the bra X minus alpha is equal
to the bra X t dagger minus alpha by the
definition of an adjoint operator but we
also showed earlier that the adjoint of
T alpha is equal to t minus alpha so we
can rewrite this whole expression as the
bra x and t alpha the second property of
the translation operator i want to look
at is its Taylor expansion so we can see
the translation by an infinitesimal
amount minus epsilon and by the
definition of the translation operator
this is e to the I epsilon P over H bar
and it will Taylor expand the
exponential we obtain 1 plus I epsilon
over H bar P plus a term of order
epsilon squared these two properties of
the translation operator are extremely
useful in many quantum mechanical
problems and you can find links in the
description to multiple videos where I
use them thoroughly to finish let's
summarize what we have learned in this
video we have started with the position
operator X and the momentum operator P
whose commutator is IH bar and we have
defined a translation operator T alpha
as e to the minus I alpha P over H bar
we have found that this operator has
some interesting properties which
include the fact that its adjoint is
equal to its inverse so it is unitary
and
these terms are equal to t minus alpha
using this properties we have then shown
that the action of t alpha on a cat X is
equal to a different cat X plus alpha
confirming that the T alpha operator is
a translation operator that translates a
cat X by an amount alpha in this video
we have learned about translation
operator that tells us about moving
quantum states from one point to another
so what next
quite a few consequences of translation
operator perhaps the two most famous
ones or the fact that the real space
wave function is related to momentum
space wave function by a Fourier
transform and the second one is the fact
that the action of the momentum operator
on wave functions is such that it
calculates their derivative I hope you
like the video and if you want to send
suggestion for future videos please
subscribe